i'm going to tell you something that's
going to sound really weird for some of
you
react does not have any idea what the
browser is
react is a component framework and its
job
is to manage state and keep track of
when
these components should update
but how does react then live in the
browser
and update your html state
and your elements you might recognize a
line of code i'm going to show you now
and you usually find it in a file called
index.js
in your react project and it looks like
this
this is the layer that talks to react
and react on the document object model
in your project so this react dom
package
is actually forming the updates on the
dom
when all these different life cycle
events happen
inside react so when there's a state
change
that you send to react react is gonna
tell
react don that this has happened and
react dom is gonna handle the updates
of the actual html tags and why am i
telling you this
well because today we're doing something
really cool
we're going to use react to build a 3d
environment
inside 3js and to do that we're going to
use
a package called react 3 fiber
so this will be a canvas running
webgl and we're going to use
react to place things in our 3d
webgl rendered world
and we can even use physics
and we can also animate movements and
shapes more thing changing size and so
on
in the react way and i think this is
really really cool
and it's gonna take very few lines of
code
since we can use abstracted components
like we're used to in react so let's
jump into the code and get started
okay so let's look at the code so
we start at the index.js file
and as you can see we are using react
dom to render the app
into the document but
if we go into app now we can see that
the outermost component
inside app is canvas and that means that
anything inside the canvas any component
we put there
will not be rendered by react-dom
anymore but will be rendered by react-3
fiber
and it will not be your standard dom
element it will be
elements inside 3js so basically
components inside a 3d environment
so inside here we have access to a bunch
of components
from react3 fiber and we don't have to
import them in order to use them i will
show you
in just a minute how that works so right
now our canvas is totally empty
just looks like this so we want to add
something to look at
so i would suggest that we add a box
so let's create a box function
that will return a mesh
and inside the mesh we need to have
a geometry and we also need to add a
material to the mesh
so our geometry will looks like this
will look like this a box buffer
geometry
and we also need to attach as geometry
and then we're going to add a material
and we're going to use a material called
mesh lambert material
if you want to read more about the
different materials you can do that in
the 3js documentation
we attach it as a material and we set a
color to it
and now we can add the box
to our canvas
so let's look in the dome
we have a black box but we can't do
anything with this it just
looks like a 2d box and in order to
explore what this box actually is
there is a great component that we can
import
from a package called dre so we import
orbit controls
from
dre
and now we can add that to our canvas
orbit controls
so now if i click and drag
we can see that this shape
is changing and maybe you can see that
it is actually a 3d box that is spinning
around
following my mouse but this
is totally black so what we need to do
now is to add some
lights to the scene so let's first
add an ambient light so this is just
a light that is everywhere shining on
every surface okay
so not much changed except that the
black became pink but
the shape looks the same
so we want to get some perspective of
this box
and to do that we're gonna have a
spotlight shining
from the side so we do a spotlight
but let's add some props to this because
this one needs to shine from an
angle and we set at a position
and the way that you do that
is to set it as props like this
so now let's see what it looks like
now we're starting to see that this is
an actual 3d shape
so that's pretty cool
but the background looks a bit boring
now it's just
totally black and it's nothing there a
box in nothingness
so from dre we can also import another
cool component
called stars and it is
actually exactly what it sounds like
it's a starry sky
oh so now we can see that this box is
actually floating in space here and we
get some perspective
and if we zoom out really far we can see
what is
actually happening here so we can see
that
it is inside a huge sphere looks like
the observable universe
our next step i think should be to add
a ground to this box so we will add a
plane
so let's copy this one and we'll add a
plane
okay this is not a box buffer geometry
it's
a plane and we want
to make sure that this plane is lower
than the box
and the default position of the box is
zero zero zero
for x y zed now let's add the plane
to our scene
i think i forgot to set
the size of this plane and that we can
do with the args prop
so i'll set it 100 times 100
we'll set the color to be light blue
so now we have a plane here
but the plane is vertical so we want to
rotate this plane
90 degrees so we add a rotation prop
to the plane and we rotate it by minus
math dot pi zero zero
and i think we also need to to get to 90
degrees we need to divide it by two
there we have it but now we want to race
either lower the plane or raise the box
a bit
so we'll set the box position to two
let's see if that is the right way
yeah that's the right way so now we have
it floating
slightly above the plane so the next
thing we should do is to add some
physics to this box
and then there's a library that we can
utilize to do this
and that library is called use canon
so we will import
use box
from use
the physics library is called canon js
but there is a package called use canon
that
allows us to use these hooks to inject
physics
on our react 3 fiber components
so the components we want to have
in our physics environment
should be wrapped in a physics
component
like that and let's see if yeah now it
auto imported physics for us
so inside the box component now
we need to get a ref
to this physics box representation
so we use use box and then
we give it a callback from this callback
we return an object
so here we can give it some properties
let's set
mass to one so it has some
if it doesn't have mass then how is
gravity going to affect it
and then we need to set this ref to this
mesh
so now let's see what happens
oh the box starts falling the box falls
through the plane now and that is
because we haven't added the plane to
our
canon hook yet
so let's do something similar here
but our plane should not have a mass
because it should not be affected by
gravity
or this hook should be use plane not use
box okay so now we've set the rotation
correctly both on the mesh and on the
use canon hook
and for the box we set the position on
both of them
so now when we look in the browser
we see that the box lands on the plane
so that's awesome
and the last thing i want to do i want
to see if i can affect this box a little
bit
with the mouse so on the box mesh
we just set an on click properly
that takes a call back here and inside
this callback we want to affect the box
so how do we do that
well from use canon we don't only get
the ref
we also get an api
so this api we can affect the properties
of this box
so if we do api dot
set dot velocity dot set
so we see how we can set the x y instead
and we want it to
jump up a bit when we click it so we'll
set something like that
so let's see if that works
so i can get it to fly a bit here
so that's pretty cool so
it would be cool to become even better
at this and then
try to build a 3d game i think that
would be a
really cool goal to have and if any one
of you do that please
send me a link to the repo or a website
where i can try out the game would be
super cool
i think it's pretty cool what you can
achieve in react 350 with just
50 lines of code and it's really nice
with the react way of abstracting
components
so this outermost layer that
quite describes the world and also we
can wrap
things in behaviors like this physics
wrapper
it's easy to get an overview of what is
actually
going on in the world we could also wrap
these lights in a
lights component or something like that
so i hope you learned something from
this video if you liked it then
thumbs up the video and subscribe if you
want to
so cool will see you guys next time bye
[Music]
you